[Aplausos]
en su discurso del premio nobel mario
vargas llosa dijo que lo más importante
que le había pasado fue aprender a leer
en lo personal no podría estar más de
acuerdo con él en este punto como les
contaré aprender a leer hacia uno de los
hechos más importantes que he vivido
aunque déjenme contarles que cuando en
primero de primaria lloraba porque creí
que jamás aprendería a leer
la afirmación de vargas llosa me hace
preguntarme dos cosas primero porque no
hay más personas que acepten la lectura
como un momento estelar de su vida
después en que un momento realmente
aprendemos a leer
será cuando en la primaria nos enseñan a
decodificar letras y palabras escritas
o cuando más tarde aprendemos a conducir
nuestro pensamiento para comprender lo
que modificamos
antes de responder estas preguntas
déjenme confesarles que yo he sido un
lector muy afortunado porque nadie jamás
me obligó a leer los libros fueron
apareciendo paulatinamente a lo largo de
mi vida y de la forma más afortunada que
puede haber
por ejemplo mi libro favorito es uno de
los libros más odiados que existen pero
también uno de los menos leídos
actualmente exacto el ingenioso hidalgo
don quijote de la mancha'
y es que este libro ha dejado rendido a
más de uno desde las primeras páginas
según me han contado es aburrido
anticuado y yo soy un montón de
palabrejas que lo vuelven incomprensible
sin olvidar el últim y dante grosor que
tiene algunas ediciones cierto
para mí leerlo fue muy estimulante con
digamos en el último semestre mi mejor
amigo de la preparatoria me dijo tienes
que leer este libro es la cosa más
irreverente que se haya escrito sobre la
tierra tiene acción aventuras disparates
tragedias desilusiones y mucha sabiduría
pero principalmente trata sobre seguir y
defender nuestros sueños
con esta invitación yo supere las
dificultades de lectura y me informe de
una locura que el día de hoy me ha
traído hasta aquí
por otro lado si le preguntamos es
andrés entendió de la lectura
seguramente no pasaría de la descripción
de los hechos tal vez haría énfasis en
algunas partes interesantes
pero nada más
me parece que fue hasta que lo leí en la
universidad que comencé a valorar su
hondura y su belleza y es que la
licenciatura en letras te prepara para
una lectura más compleja de pronto ya no
solo veía la anécdota sino también el
contexto el lenguaje la estructura los
personajes y un sinfín de sentimientos y
pensamientos que me hacían informarme
aún más de esa locura
y precisamente la locura ha sido una
constante durante mi paso por la
universidad no sé en qué momento entre
las múltiples excentricidades que dejan
en uno las humanidades
y apareció el mesiánico deseo de
compartir la lectura con los demás
así que el olvido que traían las
presentaciones
así que con mis amigas desarrollamos
varias pérez de lectura para fomentar la
lectura en cafés primarias secundarias e
incluso en la calle estas actividades
además de ser muy gratificantes y
divertidas estuvieron repletas de
maravillosos errores que cometimos una y
otra vez y es que cuando queremos
fomentar la lectura solemos proceder de
una manera muy semejante
primero presentamos la lectura como una
actividad divertidísima y que a todos
nos cambia la vida mágicamente y la
acompañamos de una serie de actividades
o espectáculos en los que invitamos a
que la gente escuche en el mejor de los
casos lea el texto que seleccionamos
para ellos
indudablemente cuando esto se hace bien
resulta agradable tanto para chicos como
para grandes
pero si el día de hoy tuviera yo la
oportunidad de encontrarme a cada uno de
los que alguna vez nos escucharon y les
preguntarán
después de la sesión que tuvimos ha
desarrollado un hábito de lectura
ha aumentado la cantidad de libros que
has leído
consideras que la calidad de tu lectura
ha aumentado desde entonces
seguramente la respuesta a estas tres
preguntas sería no
y es una respuesta natural porque estas
actividades animan a la lectura
pero no forman lectores
para explicarles que quiero decir con
esto y como llegué estas conclusiones
antes déjenme contarles otra anécdota
cuando se cumplieron los 400 años de la
muerte de cervantes me dieron la
oportunidad de dar un par de charlas
sobre el príncipe de los ingenios una en
el colegio franco inglés y otra en la
facultad de ciencias agrícolas
emocionado consigue este maravilloso
disfraz y prepare una muy divertida
charla sobre el quijote
en aquella ocasión no hable de las
repercusiones históricas de la obra ni
de las proezas artísticas de cervantes
sino de lo importante de vivir la
lectura de cómo es posible transportar
las aventuras de un par de personajes a
nuestra vida y transformar la realidad
fue precisamente esta actitud quijotesca
junto con un par de talleres de lectura
y escritura los que convencieron a los
doctores gonzalo cosas y sergio y lario
de invitarme a trabajar a la facultad de
ciencias agrícolas como podrán imaginar
este hecho fue muy importante para mí
pero lo fue principalmente porque me
presentó una realidad que yo no había
contemplado hasta entonces
leer
va mucho más allá de la litera
en la universidad leer es la herramienta
más importante para los alumnos porque
les permite construir conocimientos
perdurables de calidad y con futuras
aplicaciones
sin embargo hay un problema un problema
muy importante
los alumnos universitarios no están
leyendo y no saben cómo leer
ahora ustedes me preguntarán cómo no
saben leer si vargas llosa aprendió a
leer a los 5 años igual que nosotros no
bueno de minuto
gracias al trabajo junto al doctor
perfilar yo en la materia de
comunicación profesional y el programa
fomento a la lectura nos hemos dedicado
a comprender las deficiencias de lectura
de nuestros alumnos y proponer
soluciones que no sólo modifiquen su
disposición hacia los libros sino que
mejoren su desempeño académico
lo primero que necesitan saber es que en
la universidad los alumnos necesitan
comprender conceptos muy complejos de
diversas disciplinas desarrollar hábitos
mentales relacionados con la
investigación y el aprendizaje y
formarse un compromiso a largo plazo con
el conocimiento
para hacer todo esto es indispensable
aprender a través de textos muy
complicados como son artículos ensayos
ponencias tesis monografías etcétera ya
que a través de este tipo de textos un
conocimiento especializado se genera se
estabiliza y se difunde dentro de un
campo de conocimiento por eso también su
lectura resulta tan diferente de la
lectura de una novela por ejemplo
aprender a leer no es una actividad
mecánica y homogénea
por eso requiere una instrucción
pero cuando a un alumno ha tenido una
instrucción
hemos detectado como primera deficiencia
en la gran mayoría de nuestros alumnos
que carecen del hábito de lectura esto
se debe además de su contexto familiar a
que durante su trayectoria académica
leer se ha reducido a identificar una
información muy específica en un texto
ya sea para responder un ensayo vamos a
llamarle así ensamblar un trabajo
escrito
esto nos lleva al verdadero conflicto de
la lectura universitaria
los alumnos no reconocen una necesidad
real de lectura les basta con memorizar
la exposición del profesor o los apuntes
de clase y muchos profesores desconocen
una metodología para formar lectores a
partir de su asignatura
pero no solo es la falta de lectura sino
la falta de calidad en la lectura lo que
está generando aprendizajes memorísticos
mecánicos y sin sentido
la lectura como les comentaba no es ni
mecánica
ni homogénea no todos lo aprendemos
igual pero existe una instrucción
metodológica en la que el alumno puede
aprender cómo regular su propia lectura
garantizar la información vincularla con
otros conocimientos y evitar las
distracciones
por ejemplo una de las estrategias
básicas de lectura es detenerse
periódicamente para revisar lo que hemos
leído
de acuerdo con una encuesta que
realizamos el año pasado el 68% de
nuestros alumnos realiza esa estrategia
esto es una fortaleza cuando esa pausa
la usamos para asegurarnos que
comprendimos vincularlo con otros
conocimientos etcétera pero que creen
que nos confesaron los alumnos cuando
nos entrevistamos con ellos
nos confesaron que realizan esa pausa
porque perdieron la concentración
desconoce en el léxico especializado los
confunde la complejidad misma del texto
pero principalmente porque no están
leyendo para comprender se detienen
porque quieren asegurarse de memorizar
toda la información del libro no lo cual
está muy descabellado
por esta razón cada espacio académico
debe preocuparse ya no solo de la
animación lectora que es lo que yo hice
en un inicio sino de la formación de
lectores competentes
es decir lectores que comprenden e
interpretan lo que leen que no sólo de
codifican palabras y memorizar
información tienen un propósito de
lectura saben cómo realizar la actividad
saben vincularon los conocimientos con
otros evitar distracciones tienen un
hábito etcétera
conscientes de todo ello en la facultad
de ciencias agrícolas hemos desarrollado
una serie de actividades para generar
una comunidad de lectores competentes
actualmente estamos trabajando en un
proyecto que me entusiasma mucho cuya
emoción quiero compartirles el día de
hoy la construcción del café literario
el amor voy a decir una vez más pero
esta educación y esto que cuando diga el
nombre de todos me acompañen con una
ovación y un aplauso vale esperemos
verme
la construcción del café literario el
amor
en este espacio además de ofrecer café y
libros nos encargaremos de darle
seguimiento a la formación de futuros
lectores y escritores universitarios
además de generar un ambiente agradable
a través de números artísticos talleres
charlas conferencias y otro tipo de
actividades vinculados con la ciencia la
tecnología y el arte y estoy seguro de
que cada uno de ustedes tanto los que se
encuentran aquí como los que nos ven
alrededor del mundo nos ayudarán a
construir este sueño y fíjense que
precisamente esa es una de las virtudes
de la literatura formar los sueños por
eso también debe ser parte de las
lecturas obligatorias de todo
universitario
yo les he hablado de un libro que me ha
llevado a situaciones maravillosas
gracias a que me dijo que soñar es
importante y como pueden observar la
locura también es importante
pero ahora quiero ser congruente con mi
información lectora y hacer una última
crítica al santo patrono de los libros
don quijote
don quijote sin duda es un hombre de una
alta condición moral y lleno de nobles
ideales él además de buscar los honores
de un caballero andante quiere cambiar
el mundo y la forma en que vivimos en él
tanto así que de haber existido en el
siglo 17 él hubiera participado en la
real y pontificia teta
pero en esta decirles una cosa que se
comenta poco que no se sabe sobre este
personaje y que es muy importante
al quijote
nada le sale bien
jamás gana una batalla
y es que tanto para el caballero de la
triste figura como para quienes nos
encargamos de fomentar la lectura las
buenas intenciones no son suficientes
los grandes errores de nuestro personaje
son
y actuar de manera irreflexiva no
considerar otros puntos de vista y no
dejar en claro nuestros propósitos y
metodologías por eso quiero que seamos
más como sancho panza y pasemos de la
ignorancia a la comprensión
aprender a leer es importante dijo
vargas llosa
a los 6 años adquirimos el código
escrito y desde entonces adquirimos
también un compromiso con nosotros
mismos
yo creo que quien dice que no le gusta
leer realmente quiere decirnos que aún
no sabe cómo leer
en mi caso la libertad y la pasión
fueron muy importantes para sobrellevar
las molestias que implica la lectura
por eso cuando queremos invitar a otras
personas a realizar esta actividad
queremos contagiar las de nuestro
entusiasmo eso es importante por
supuesto pero hay que recordar que
existen otras necesidades de lectura y
que todas en mayor o menor medida
requieren de que seamos conscientes de
cómo y para qué realizamos esa actividad
por último no no quiero invitar a nadie
a leer el quijote
solo quiero decirles que formar lectores
es una actividad apasionante porque uno
pelea contra los mismos tres gigantes
contra los que peleo el caballero de los
leones
el miedo la injusticia y la ignorancia
vale muchas gracias
[Aplausos]